ça souviens-tu on jouait du piano il ne
révèle pas d'abord philippe parent a été
professeur de chant fais le toi mon cher
pour jouer du piano
voilà quand elle le met devant son piano
sa fille anne-marie retrouve le père
qu'il a été le petit appartement est une
véritable galerie d'art parce qu'il a
également fait de la peinture
tout ça est resté en lui et tout ce qui
est artistique c'est lié à des émotions
monsieur parent est un des artistes qui
a participé à la murale des sociétés
alzheimer à travers le québec
mais il n'en a plus souvenir il m'a dit
qu'il se souvenait plus si l'art fait du
bien aux patients reste qu'on est loin
de traitement ce qui est un peu j'en
voyais le moule décourageant c'est que
les résultats des 20 dernières années en
termes d'efficacité de nouvelles
molécules de nouveaux traitements qui
nous montre vraiment un échelle aux
incisives dans la maladie bailleurs ne
pollue les médicaments existants
permettent seulement de ralentir le
développement de la maladie
l'hôpital maisonneuve rosemont participe
à deux études cliniques internationales
une sur un nouveau médicament en phase 3
on sait qu'il est sécuritaire mais il
faut maintenant mesurer son efficacité
généralement ça peut prendre dix ans
très inquiétant avant qu'on peut savoir
le médicament sur le marché
puis quand on est rendu à la phase 4
c'est vraiment son aile presqu un seul
marché des cinq patients sélectionnés et
leurs répondants sont entourés de toute
une équipe
le protocole est stricte et on doit
préserver l'objectivité pour continuer
ses multicanaux quand même parce que bon
ce sont les standards de traitement et
par dessus ces médicaments alors on va
rajouter notre médicament de recherche
ou un placebo
jamais le médecin et le patient le
personnel est au courant de ce qu'on va
donner aux pas faire les grégoire se
sentent privilégiés
même s'il faut souvent venir à l'hôpital
pendant les deux ans que durent ces
cliniques sans savoir si c'est le
placebo qui est administrée
c'est aujourd'hui je voulais faire une
belle thiviers
faut que cela reste impossible vieille
là c'est plus que 70 ans dans ma tête là
l'autre cheval de bataille c'est la
prévention on voit que des interventions
plus jeunes c'est l'état siens mais
compteront des coupables habitué à
l'hypertension le cholestérol le diabète
la sédentarité le tabagisme ce qu'on
enlève ces facteurs là on recule
la survenue de la maladie d'azheimer de
façon significative et ça c'est
documenté les manger faute de pouvoir
guérir
il faut prévenir le nombre de cas aura
doublé dans 25 ans ici à nourrice
despatie radio canada montréal